all right so the clarification request
was on Coq Hole uh as it was presented
in a video which I will link in the
comments section okay
uh the first thing is the whole of koku
hole is not the whole uho nage so that
whole does not mean Direction it's not
Coq Direction
is four directional throw shivonage in
Japanese so the sound is the same but
the kanji is different Coke you hold
that hole means a method so koku ho is a
method for cultivating Coq that's what
it is
[Music]
um
is an aspect
or an element of the internal aspects in
particular it is
um his uh young energy being allowed to
enter my body
go down in my body
feel the Earth Energy
and they will thereby pressurize my body
okay
that can then be released and that
causes what we call a Coq projection so
let us here Define then uh kokyoho is a
method for cultivating the pressurizing
of your person with their young energy
combining with the Earth Energy okay
okay
um
let's see some things in the video that
are uh that need repeating here okay the
first thing in our first video on kokuho
our Gateway video on koku hole we were
told that as a method for training it's
not self-defense I'm not sitting at a
Japanese restaurant and somebody goes
that's mine that's not what's happening
um they are doing a particular
prescribed movement that is organized
for the cultivation of Coq as I just
described it so in that sense they are
prescribed to do a Coq projection into
my Center okay and that is the tactic of
spinal displacement so they're not here
grabbing this really hard it's not a
wrist grab that I'm trying to get out of
uh it's not some I don't like my hands
here let me get out of it the uke is
prescribed to themselves do a Coq
projection that immediately starts that
Coq pressurizing in his body so the Coq
projection it looks like this
that's my prescribed role in the method
of cultivation here okay
um
some things particularly said in the
video before I go on to the question in
particular is
you are not going back
to somebody who's like holding me in
place so this new kid now is not doing
the drill
they are just squeezing my wrists do you
see that
and you're not gonna go back
to do some sort of Leverage disadvantage
to them where you can now do two young
uh thing two young energies on your hand
again in our video in our Gateway video
I do go backwards
but I have a Yin hand and a young hand I
have the outer spiral on this hand the
inward spiral on this hand I was fire in
this hand water on this hand and Coke
you on this hand and Ivy on this hand
Okay the reason that I went back was
because as that young energy is coming
into me and pressurizing I am going to
circulate it in the uh Tom din of my
body I'm in the in the internal field
the lower tonden I am going to circulate
it and prolong its presence in my body
so I'm I am going back but it's for the
purposes of circulating that pressure
that she in my body oh
meaning it's not for leverage so I don't
need any leverage because his energy is
not here at the risk his energy is
pressurized uh and bouncing off the
Earth so I can throw from here just as
easily as I had thrown from here as
gookin okay
likewise when I go back I don't have to
worry about how far I go back in terms
of Leverage and things like that uh
because it's not like I would lose the
ability to internalize his energy so
this is pretty far back I would say and
he pushes he's not going to push me
anywhere and you can still project from
there too okay
that's not why I was going back that
does not Mark how far I go back Leverage
is not the uh Catalyst there
also the same thing goes with my arms I
don't
have to worry about where my arms are in
other words I'm not out here for a
mechanical reason I'm out here for that
ritual reason this is the shape
of the inner spiral the fire element the
young element and so cute element
in the keyhole in the in the ritual
you're doing in the Tokyo Hall you're it
doesn't matter where your hands are go
ahead it doesn't matter he's pushing it
doesn't matter he's not going to push me
over it's all just pressurizing
and you can do you can do same thing
okay
so all that to say
you're doing Coq a particular way a
cookie hole a particular way because
that is the prescribed ritual for
cultivating Coke you you're not trying
to uh gain or stop yourself from losing
a mechanical advantage
um and nor are you dealing with someone
that's doing a wrist wrap and you have
to try to throw him and all that kind of
stuff that's all that's all bull argue
none of that's true okay
now to the question
you have a guy
who comes in and pushes down on your
hands
what do you do
hey okay you're supposed to do a Coq
projection you're supposed to push
through my Center
that's what you that would be the first
solution they're not training correctly
fix them in the form
to me it is the same thing if I have a
spotter
and their spot me on bench press they're
supposed to help me bring that barbell
out to my nipple line they're not
supposed to Chuck it towards my feet and
then I show through my ego attachment
that I can hold it on the nipple line
you're not a good spotter
does that make sense okay
if you can't do that I would go get
another partner if no one in your dojo
can do it I would leave the dojo flat
out there's nothing going on there
if however you're not doing coke you
whole
and you're working on
um bringing
takamusu aiki into koku Hall
such that he's he is going to uh do any
kind of projections very similar
similar to the game we play here where
he tries to touch my chest he can touch
my chest any way that he wants to and I
have to stop him from doing it so he
goes and I am doing the same Coke you
home and the same uh IQ adhesions Coq
projections even though he is trying to
get out of all of those things and
trying to touch my chest so maybe your
UK is coming down right
um a lot of times especially is after
you throw them and then they kind of
come up do you see like that okay well
if he's gonna change the rules you can
still do Coke you home he goes up and he
can't he can't ever get down he can't
get down he can't get in a position to
do this so I will uh hyper-exaggerate it
let's say he goes up
and he go he's going to drop his weight
uh into season
see that kind of thing you get that
um the same thing he goes up he can't
get down
don't let him down if you don't want to
or you combine
the uh internal and the external so he
goes right and pull me and you come
around
so we'll do that slower so you can see
it go slower he's got his weight well I
will externally yield and then go back
to the external project question as I
load the hand for the Coq
that doesn't change
he goes to show my hands down
the same thing you don't you don't have
to let your hands get there okay so
first Solutions tell them to train
correctly second solutions would be uh
do an external yield to that and then go
back to an internal projection and then
um I'm sorry the second solution was
don't let them ever get down you can
hold them up with Coq okay then the
third solution was an external yield and
Then followed by an internal projection
[Music]
um
the other one is he's got you here uh
again
I don't think you're doing Coq hole at
this point
so you'll find people
go ahead and push and they'll do all
kinds of little leverage tricks so he's
pushing and uh I can just get so much
torque here that I'm out do you see and
go let's have you just stay there push
push push push push and I can get so
much torque here that I'm out and stay
there where you are I'm gonna move out
from under you stay exactly where you
are his body shifted slightly to the
left
go back
so as his body shifted just ever so
slightly again then you can project on
this side so you're here
or
oh you're down here he's got it uh with
relaxed tension-free movement he can't
he can't hold me down
there's just no way he's you really got
it and I just kind of lift my hands up
and
back in that so he can be standing on it
and he has lots of weight he might try
to chance it won't work but if I just
Lift My Hands Up In Space you can do it
okay
um but none of that to me is Coke you
whole train Coqui Hall is he pressurizes
that Center
and I'm going to allow it to pressurize
and then release it out through his
Center through his Center
foreign
[Music]
so sometimes
I don't even do this throw
oh just that was it
oh
my God
I just want that
that is Ikea at the energetic level
okay so you're doing the training at
that energetic level
um which I wrote about today in that
blog entry what is I keep